hello and welcome to Khan Academy live
SAT I'm Eric I'm an SAT tutor and one of
the SAT experts here at Khan Academy and
I'm so excited to be with you today and
over the course of the next few weeks as
we cover SAT math reading and writing
with one class a week now before we get
into SAT math which is our topic for
today I want to give you a quick
overview of what's coming up for each of
the next few weeks let's take a look so
like I mentioned today's class is going
to cover SAT math next week on Tuesday
May 23rd at 7 p.m. Eastern 4 p.m.
Pacific I'm going to cover SAT writing
followed by SAS SAT reading rather
followed by SAT writing and you'll see
that all of these classes will happen at
Tuesdays at the exact same time so if
you're able to make it today you'll also
be able to make it for the following
classes and you know if you can't make
any of these classes don't worry we'll
record all of the classes and send out
the recordings so that you can watch
each of the classes whenever is most
convenient for you and so that's a sneak
peek at what's coming up over the next
few weeks and for today let's take a
look at what we'll cover within SAT math
so for today the first thing I'm going
to cover is how to avoid careless
mistakes and the reason I want to cover
this is that you know careless mistakes
are a possibility for anyone and on any
topic within SAT math and so it's a you
know great to start out with as a
foundation the next thing I want to
cover is function notation and this is
another one of those really common
concepts that I can show up in a variety
of ways in the SAT and third I'll cover
graph problems graphing table problems
on the SAT and I'm covering this because
not only do graphs and tables show up
with an SAT Math but with the evidence
based reading and writing sections
you'll often come across graphs and
tables that you'll be asked to interpret
and relate back to the author's point
and then last but not least I'll wrap up
with a Khan Academy badge for attending
this class and answer any questions at
the end on anything that I covered for
the day and so with
a lot of a lot of top a lot of topics to
cover today and so let's dive straight
in start doing some math and doing some
practice problems so first how should
you avoid careless mistakes in the SAT
math so what I'll share today is one
approach that has really helped me be
more organized and methodical and cut
down on the number of error careless
mistakes that I make and I've found that
a lot of other students also find it
helpful and so the first step I
encourage you to take is to read and
understand the question one part at a
time and so when you break things up and
annotate and underline as you go it will
help you process all of the information
and keep you focused on the question
next I encourage you to write out the
steps you need to take to solve the
problem and so this will prevent you
from going one step too far or too short
and so this is really helpful and is
almost like a road map for what you want
to do first second third and so forth
next you really want to do the math on
paper or on the calculator and no matter
how confident you might be feeling I
really discourage you from doing - from
doing this in your head as it really ups
the chances that you make a careless
mistake and so put it on paper type it
out in your calculator and then last but
not least mark down the answer in your
test booklet and so if you have ABCD
like this you can circle a or you can
write out a and block it and this is all
about making sure that once you have the
right answer that answer gets to your
the bubble sheet and so for steps that I
like to follow we didn't understand the
question second write out the steps you
need to take third do the math on paper
or on the calculator and then finally
mark down the answer in your test
booklet and so I this process is one
that I try and use regardless of what
I'm working on whether it's quadratic
formula or right triangle questions or
function notation problems and so give
this process a try and what we'll do now
is instead of just walking through the
concept apply
this will in the context of real SAT
math questions and so let's take a look
at our first one and I'm going to zoom
in here just to make sure that everyone
can read it so in this first question
I'm going to read the question first so
which of the following expressions is
equivalent to the above expression and
so it's a pretty straightforward
question and so I understand that and
then I want to figure out the steps I
want to take and so there this is you've
got notice you've got some
multiplication and you've got some
subtraction and so I want to do multiply
first and then I want to do the
subtraction and so this is some good
order of operations and if you want a
quick refresher on order of operations
head over to Khan Academy and do a quick
search but for now I'll just rewrite
this here and start doing some of the
math negative 5 Z minus 2 minus Z times
3 minus Z and before I go any further I
want to note that you know it's
important for questions like this to
really differentiate your two and your
Z's so that you don't get them confused
because if you if you do it really does
change the the answer that you might get
and so if I go ahead and continue with
this problem negative 5 Z minus and then
what I'm going to do here is I'm going
to foil too so do some foil polynomial
multiplication and so that stands for
first out inner last and so this is foil
and so if I multiply the first terms the
2 times the 3 is going to be 6 the outer
terms the 2 times the negative Z is
going to be minus 2z the inner terms are
going to be minus 3z so the negative z
times 3 and then i've got the negative z
times negative z and so that's going to
be a positive z squared and so I still
have this negative sign but I've done
this multiplication and now I'm just
going to combine some like terms still
leave that negative sign out there so
I've got 6 minus 5 Z plus Z squared and
now I can distribute this negative sign
and so if I have this negative 5
z- times six is going to be minus six
this negative one times this negative
five z is going to be plus 5z and then
this negative times this plus z squared
is going to lead to negative z squared
and now again i can continue with the
second step of subtraction and i've got
this negative 5z and this positive 5z
and so these will cancel out leaving me
with negative six minus Z squared which
is also the same as negative Z squared
minus six and so then I look over here
and I've got negative C Z squared minus
six and so my answer choice is C and
that last step I do is I will mark down
C and make it very clear so there's no
chance of making a mistake when I carry
it over to the bubble sheet so that is
an example one example of how you can
apply this more organized process within
a question that has a few steps and
where order matters now that that
question it may have been
straightforward for you it might have
been more challenging but go ahead and
do some practice and what we'll do next
is a slightly different problem with a
little bit more information we're using
more organized processes even more
helpful so let's take a look
okay so I'm going to zoom out just a
little bit here so let's give this
question a read a distributorships dvds
to several stores the shipping boxes
contain several DVDs in their cases plus
a layer of padding at each end of the
boxes okay
the DVD cases and layers of padding can
be arranged neatly inside each box each
DVD case is fourteen millimeters thick
and each layer of padding is ten
millimeters thick and the length of the
interior of the box is 132 millimeters
if D represents the number of DVDs that
this the distributor can fit into one
box with two layers of padding which of
the following inequalities best models
this situation so I don't know about you
but that was a good bit of information
and a lot of sentences and so what's
helpful at this point is to break down
the question one part at a time and to
pull out the relevant information and so
we have DVDs that are fourteen
millimeters thick and then we have
padding so I'm just going to abbreviate
pad is ten millimeters thick and then we
have the length of the interior of the
box so the box is going to be 132
millimeters thick and then D is the
number of DVDs in one box and then one
box with two layers of padding and so
that's important with two layers of
padding and so now I have all of the
information I need from the from the
paragraph and I can start to process it
and what's even more helpful here is to
draw a diagram and so this goes back to
figuring out what steps you need to take
and also doing a lot on paper and so if
I start with this I know that this box
is 132
meters thick and then I've got two
layers of padding and we've got padding
at each end of the box as you see here
and so I've got this padding here and
I've got this padding here and that's
going to be ten millimeters and ten
millimeters so that makes sense and then
within this I've got a number of DVDs
being put inside and so these are all
you know DVDs DVDs so on so forth and
each of these is fourteen millimeters
based on what I have here and so now
with this diagram and these labels I
know that my one side of the inequality
is going to be 132 millimeters and
that's the size of the box and it all
has to fit within the box and then I
have these the padding that I can work
with and so I've got this and I bet this
so that feels like something I can start
with and so that is going to be 20 and
then within the box I've got 14
millimeter thick DVDs and since D
represents the number of DVDs I can
write this as 14 D plus 20 so 14
millimeters thick per DVD times the
number of DVDs plus 24 the padding
should be less than an equal to 132 and
so then that is going to be my final
answer B so in this example you saw that
really breaking down the question in
each into each of its parts pulling that
information out figuring out how you
want to solve the problem and then
drawing a diagram and doing it all on
paper was a good way to keep yourself
organized as you solve the problem and
ensure that you didn't make any mistakes
along the way now that's the last
careless mistake focus problem but the
same process that we walk through I'm
also going to apply in all of the other
sample problems that we walk through
today since like I mentioned it's not
just for algebra it's not just for word
problems it can really help you with a
cross SAT the SAT math test and so next
up we're going to look at some function
notation I'm going to do a quick
overview and then do some practice
problems together okay let's take a look
so first in this function notation recap
I want to talk about what is a function
so in function notation
well a function and I'll do some
abbreviation it takes in an input does
some number crunching and then creates
an output and so you might have seen
this written in your algebra class as f
of X or of as G of X or H of X and in
this case X is going to be your input
and then all of the letters F G and H
are just different ways of denoting a
function and so an example of a function
might be f of x equals x plus 2 and a
few common ways you might see this on
the SAT is within a table format so you
might see something like this and so for
given values of x f of X is going to be
2 3 & 4 and similarly you can represent
this graphically so X for certain values
of X on the x-axis and then f of X on
the y-axis if you have 0 1 & 2 you have
again along the y-axis 1 2 3 4 the same
thing the same function can be
represented as this line and so for
corresponding values of x you have
values of f of X now the last thing I
want to give a quick overview of is
compositions of functions so f of G of X
is another common expression that you'll
see on the SAT math section and this
might also be written like this it all
means the same thing though and what you
want to remember here is that you want
to solve this first by solving the
inside so this in this case it would be
G of X and then solving for the outside
components which would be F of G of X
and so this is a quick overview of
function notation that should get you
started with SAT Math and so what we're
going to do next is see what this looks
like in the context of real SAT math
questions and what's coming up are four
problems and so there are two pairs each
so the first pair the first problem in
each pair I'm going to walk through and
work through together but if you feel
comfortable then in the second question
of that pair go ahead and you know mute
me and go do the problem more
independently if you're comfortable and
then check back in to see how I did it
and so you know only if you're
comfortable otherwise you can watch me
walk work through it as well but like I
mentioned four problems total two pairs
each and so let's take a look okay so
I'll zoom in a little bit more make sure
everyone can see and so the graphs of
the functions F and G are shown to the
left what is the value of F of G of zero
rounded to the nearest whole number and
so I know that and then I want to look
at this graph and so I've got F and I've
got G and all of their corresponding
values and so the steps I want to take
to solve this are to solve for the
inside and then the outside and so I
want to solve for G of 0 first and then
I want to solve for F of G of 0 and like
I said this is kind of my road map and
so I written out the steps and then it
just comes down to following the steps
and so it's a easier for me to follow
along so if I look at G of 0 what is the
value of G when x is 0 well it looks
like I'm just right here and so that Y
value is 0 and so what I can do is
substitute in that 0 and so then this in
the place of G of 0 and so this becomes
F of 0 so when x is 0 what is the value
of F it's just going to be right there
at 5
so you've seen now one example of
function notation questions in a
graphical form and the next question
will be similar to this and so if you
feel like you have a good understanding
go ahead and read the question read
ahead work ahead and feel free to mute
me if if you want to so you can work
independently and then come back here to
the livestream after just a minute and
you'll see how I worked through it so
let's look at the next one and if you
feel comfortable go ahead and work ahead
okay
so consider the graphs of the function f
and the function G is shown above which
of the following best approximates the
value of G of F of 3 ok so G of F of 3
I've got another composition here now
how might I solve this so similar to the
last question and I want to solve the
inner part and then the outer part and
so I've got F over here I've got G over
here and so I want to solve for this is
G of F of 3 just makes it easier more
used to seeing it written like that so
in the function notation question if you
if you prefer this way or if you prefer
this way feel free to write it however
is easier for you to interpret so I've
got F of 3 and then I've got G of F of 3
and so F of 3 so when X is 3 what is the
value of F well it looks like I'm right
here and so I'm going over to 6 and so
then I can substitute in this 6 in the
place of F of 3 and this becomes G of 6
so when X is 6 I'm now looking at G here
when X is 6 what is the value of F well
if I trace our value of G rather if I
trace this up like head over here and
that value is going to be 5 and so again
as a final step
I marked down the right answers so that
I don't miss bubble anything to my
answer sheet so you've now seen two
graphical examples of function notation
questions on the SAT and hopefully you
know if you are working independently on
that you are able to follow along and
get to the right answer but if you want
more practice with that kind of question
you can also have the Khan Academy to do
that function notation practice now
we're going to shift gears a little bit
and the next two problems will be in
more of an algebraic context and again
these two will be I'll work through the
first one and then for the second one if
you feel comfortable go ahead and work
ahead of me and see if you get to the
same answer that I do
let's take a look yes and ignore the big
blue highlighting wanted to block out
some of the markings there so let's give
this question a read let G of X equal 8
X minus 5 which of the following is
equivalent to G of G of X so in this
case there it looks like there's going
to be some substitution so substitution
going on and I'm working now with
variables instead of graphs but I can
follow some of the same processes and so
this G of G of X can be simplified to be
G of 8x minus 5 so in place of that G of
X everywhere I see G of X I'm just
substituting this 8x minus 5 and so when
I have G of 8x minus 5 I can further
simplify this like this so 8 times 8x
minus 5 minus 5 so you'll see that you
know this can be rewritten as 8x minus 5
which was G of X just in place of this X
I've substituted this 8x minus 5 and so
now if I solve this I get 64 X minus 40
minus 5 and so I've got 60
or X minus 45 and then here I am here
and that is going to be answer choice B
and so in this case it was just a series
of substitutions where I again am
working from inside to out and then
solving on paper to avoid making any
careless mistakes so we're going to do
one more function notation question and
if you're if you feel pretty comfortable
with it go ahead and work ahead of me at
and but if you want to just follow along
that is completely fine as well and then
after the function notation we're going
to move on to tables and charts
so let's take a look here so let f of X
equal x over 1 over X and let G of X
equal 1 over X assuming X does not equal
0 which of the following is equivalent
to F of G of X so f of G of X so based
on the last question and how that worked
it's probably a safe assumption that
there will be some more substitution
happening and so if I solve this in
place of this G of X is the first this
is kind of solving from the inside I can
substitute in G of X and so this becomes
F of 1 over X since this is what G of x
equals and so if F of 1 over X that
means everywhere I see an X I want to
substitute 1 over X and so the algebra
there are a few more variables happening
here but the same principle applies and
so don't don't worry too much about that
and so f of X equals is up here x over 1
over X and so what that means is I would
substitute in place of this X I'm
substituting 1 over X minus 1 over again
I have another X here and I'm going to
substitute in another 1 over X now here
again order of operations matters of
operations and so I've got 1 over X and
I wanna do this division first before I
do the subtraction and when you're
dividing by a fraction it's really your
you should be multiplying by the
reciprocal of that and so what I've got
here is 1 over X minus and in this case
1 times X is X X divided by 1 is X 1
over X minus X
and that is going to be your final
answer their answer choice D so the
algebra here was a there are few more
variables that you had to work with but
the same principle applied and so if you
have a good understanding of function
notation and some of the basics you can
really scale it no matter regardless of
what equation or what format the SAT
shows the question as so that's it for
function notation questions now when
we're going to change now to an final
topic of graphs and charts and tables
and like I mentioned at the start of
class this will not only be relevant for
SAT Math but the strategies and the
approach that I am going to walk through
and walk through will also apply to SAT
reading and writing passages that often
have tables and charts at the end as
well so let's take a look at how one way
to approach chart graph and table
questions let me zoom out a little bit
there so how should you approach graph
and table problems on the SAT Math well
it boils down to one sentence and this
is one approach that I found to be
really helpful for me and other students
and that is to read the problem and
understand the graph or table before you
look at the answer choices and I want to
emphasize that you want to leave those
answer choices for the very end after
you already have a good understanding of
the graphing table and the reason you do
that is that these answer choices can
include lots of information that might
be overwhelming that might be
overwhelming or a lot to process it
might be distracting and it might also
lead you down a wrong path so it can
sometimes be be a rabbit hole that can
sway your interpretation of the data in
front of you and so the process I
encourage you to follow is to read and
understand the context from the
questions so that will give you good
kind of background information and then
interpret the axes in a graph or the row
and column labels in a table and so with
those axes you get units with the labels
you get a lot of information about what
the data means to help you interpret
finally a third rather I encourage you
to explain what you see in your own
words and this is a check for
understanding check for understanding
and so if you're able to explain this to
yourself or pretend that you're
explaining this to a friend it's a good
check and test that you understand it
enough that you could explain it to
someone else and it ensures that you
won't be swayed and in the wrong
direction by any of the answer choices
then finally you want to reread the
question and then and only then look at
the answer choices
so to recap read them read the problem
and understand the graphing table and
then look at the answer choices so that
you're not swayed or overwhelmed by all
of the information so this might be
counterintuitive or might not be exactly
how you would have thought about trying
these problems before but we're going to
give it a try over the course of some
real three SAT practice problems where
you get to see it in practice and so I
encourage you to give it a go if this
feels good and comfortable for you
consider practicing it more so that it
becomes a habit and you're faster on the
real SAT so let's take a look at a
problem
okay let's zoom and make sure you can
read this and so the graph at the at
left and the SM plane approximates the
average mileage M in miles per gallon
that Denise's pickup truck gets when she
drives at a speed of s miles per hour
what is the best interpretation of the
maximum point on the graph so that makes
sense and now I want to shift over to
the table and ignore this so don't don't
don't pay attention over here and so if
I look at the table I've got average
pickup mileage and so the title is
helpful I've got mileage there on my
y-axis I've got mileage in miles per
gallon on the x-axis I have speed and
miles per hour okay so I've got mileage
as it varies by speed and so that was
that step of explaining it in your own
words as it varies by speed and if I
interpret the graph then it looks like
as I am going as Denise is going as she
goes faster and faster up till this
maximum point here her mileage is
increasing up to a max of 18 miles per
gallon and then it drops off so that is
that makes sense and that's kind of my
interpretation of the max point and so
let's see which one of these answer
choices matches that so Denise's truck
it's a maximum mileage of 18 miles per
gallon and so I'll erase these X's since
they're no longer relevant so yeah that
matches what my interpretation of the
graph and so yep her maximum mileage per
gallon is this is that 18 and so that
works let's take a look at these other
answer choices in see what see what we
find
so Denise's truck it's a maximum mileage
of 55 miles per gallon well we just said
that the maximum mileage is here at 18
and so that 55 is out at Denise's truck
can drive at a maximum speed of 18 miles
per hour well no we know that this
x-axis is speed and we've got 70 and
you know she's still booking it so
that's out and then d Denise's truck can
drive at a maximum speed of 55 miles per
hour so that is also not the case since
again we have this 70 miles per hour and
so we can go ahead and cross that off
and so our final answer is going to be a
and we are good to go
so in that question you saw what it what
this process looks like where you read
the question understand it and then
understand the graph before you look at
the answer choices and are influenced by
them and so we're going to look at a
slightly more complex example in the
next question and again if you feel
comfortable go ahead and work ahead mute
me and then compare your answer but if
you want to follow along that works as
well so let's take a look at another
example of this
okay so let's take a look the graph at
left and the th plane shows the function
used to model height H in feet of the
top of a pool toy above the surface of
the water T seconds after the toy has
been thrown towards the surface how many
seconds after the toy had been thrown
did the pool toy resurface so how many
seconds okay so in this example we can
reread that question just to better
understand and then hop over here if we
still don't understand it
to see if the graph helps to clarify so
we've got the th plane used to model
height and feet above the tongue above
the surface of the water T seconds after
toys been thrown and the question is how
many seconds after - I have been thrown
did the pool toy resurface so if i look
nick stiff this is step number one step
number two is to understand the graph so
toy height above the water after T
seconds and so on my axes to understand
these this is height above the surface
of the water in feet so I've got height
over here and then seconds here and this
is time and so I'm throwing an object so
I'm throwing and then based on this
since this is height above the surface
of the water toy so this is above water
above water since this is the height is
above and it's positive and then this is
submerged right since since I've got
these negative feet markers here on the
left and then if I that it feels like I
have a good understanding now the graph
I know where the toy is above water and
below water and so now I can look back
at the question so how many seconds
after the toy had been thrown to the
pool toy resurfaced and so resurfacing
looks like it's going to be where do you
have an idea of where on the graph that
might be
so hopefully I've thrown in some answers
there well it seems like it's going to
be where it's above this x-axis right so
that is where that's almost like I shade
this blue it almost makes it look like
the top of the pool and so where it's
popping back up is going to be right
here since this is where the toys being
thrown this is underwater and then where
it pops back up is where it is now
positive and has some positive height
and that looks like it's at 1.1 seconds
since it's right between the 1 and 1.2
and so then my final answer there is
going to be C so in this question you
saw a little bit more complex of a graph
and you know the SAT might have simpler
graphs it might have even more complex
graphs but if you really break down the
graph piece by piece axes by title and
all of that it will help you understand
it and make sure that you aren't
intimidated or kind of worried and
overwhelmed at thinking oh man where I
have no idea what this means if you
break it down into its parts you can
build it back up and really strengthen
that understanding so the final question
I'm going to do today is a question on
tables and so tables are a bit like
graphs and so a lot of the principles
will apply but you'll see where there
are some differences in this practice
question and again here if you feel
comfortable go ahead and work ahead if
you want to follow along go ahead and do
that
okay so I'm just going to zoom in here
for now and I'm going to start over here
first the table second and then these
answer choices third so an online stores
marketing director uses a web-based
computer program to tabulate customer
responses to a survey which ask
customers whether their priority when
buying sneakers was comfort okay that
seems important comfort look or price
the results are summarized in the table
at left which of the following claims
are supported by the findings in the
table okay so I've got a survey and
about shoes and the priorities so that
makes sense and now I'm going to hop
over here to number two and I've got
this sneaker survey and I'm going to
look now at the rows and the column
headers to first ground myself and so in
the rows I've got gender and age so male
ages 13 to 34 male 35 and over and so
this is exactly like it mentioned gender
and age so this is some demographic
information and then at the top these
are the priorities that are mentioned
over here when buying sneakers so
comfort look or price and then I've got
my totals and my totals so then this
table if I state my understanding of
this is you know these are customer
priorities priorities by gender and age
since those are the segments in the rows
by gender and age so now with that
understanding I can finally go over to
number three add the third step there
and look at each of these statements so
number one males 35 and older are more
likely to purchase sneakers based on
price than how the sneaker looks and so
I want to look at males 35 and over so
males 35 and over are over here and it
says they're more likely to purchase on
price is price more important
then look so is P greater than L and so
I've got price and looks and it does
indeed look like price is more important
to males ages three five and over then
looks and so statement number one is
going to be true now I'll zoom out a
little bit here in case you're you're
working ahead statement number two males
between thirteen and thirty-four have
the highest frequency of responding and
actually I'm going to change colors here
just help color codes so males thirteen
and thirty-four had the highest
frequency of responding to the web-based
survey so now I'm looking at another
demographic so males aged 13 to 34 had
the highest frequency so in this case
highest frequency is the operative words
I'm not looking just at comfort looking
price I'm looking at their totals and so
that is going to be there on the table
and now how might I figure out if
they're if they had the highest
frequency of responding what number in
the table would I be comparing this to
so if you took a moment I'll be actually
comparing it to these numbers here and
so is 140 greater than 60 one
yes greater than eighty-nine yes greater
than twenty-seven yes and so that means
males have the most number of responses
in this survey and so statement number
two is supported last but not least
we've got statement number three so the
probability that a customer purchases
sneakers so that a customer purchases
sneakers based on price is approximately
24 percent and so in this case I'm no
longer looking at just one segment I'm
looking at all customers and then I'm
looking at price and so which elements
of the table might I will I need to see
if statement number three is supported
so if you took a moment you might have
said this row here and so I want to look
at all customers since this is just
customers not male or female or by age
and then I want to look at price here
and so it looks like this is going to be
a key number so the total number of
customers that say price is the most
important thing for them now that's one
part of the equation but what about the
second part so how would I know if this
is about 24% well I would look at the
total number of responses and so in this
case that's 75 over 317 and if you do
them do the math in you know punch that
number in on the calculator that does
get you to write about 24% and so that
is also going to be correct and
supported by the table and so then my
final answer is going to be D statements
one two and three now say you were short
on time in this question there is
actually another way you might have done
this aisle through a process of
elimination and so say you checked
statement number one out first and you
saw that statement number one was
correct well then through process of
elimination a does not have number one
in it so you know that's out B also does
not have 1 in it but C and D do so you'd
still you would have gotten it down to 2
at least then say you were here and you
confirm that statement number 2 is also
correct well then you know that C does
not have number 2 and so you can also
cross that out and by process of
elimination get to D as well so that's
the last question practice question that
I am going to go through for today on
charts and graphs and so that really is
the is the end of the concepts and the
topics for today and so I hope that you
found some of the work on careless
mistakes with SAT Math and function
notation and graphs and tables to be
helpful now to wrap things up in class
I'm going to give out and that's a a
badge for attending the class and then
take some question
so let's take a look at the badges and
how to how you'll get that and then if
you have any questions go ahead and
start typing them into the YouTube live
chat box and I'll go ahead and answer as
many as I can okay so for the badge
you're going to get a the badge link in
the YouTube live chat box and then once
you click on the badge you'll need to
log in to Khan Academy and then you'll
see a notification in the top right of
the screen and so keep an eye out for
that it'll pop up in next to this little
like bell icon that's my best
interpretation of a bell in the top
right of your screen and then like I
mentioned now I'm going to take a minute
to go through and answer some questions
and so the first question we have is
around time management strategies on SAT
math so first thing I would encourage
you to do is go to Khan Academy in our
tips and strategy sections and we have
two really good articles about time
management strategy strategies not just
for SAT math but also the reading and
writing sections now for SAT Math in
particular what I would encourage you to
do is one strategy called the two passes
strategy and so what you want to do in
the first pass is go through and answer
the questions answer as many of the
questions as you can but don't spend too
much time on any one question and the
reason for that is that all of the
questions on the SAT on math reading and
writing every correct every question is
worth the same amount of points so if
it's an easy question it's worth one
point if it's the hardest question
you've ever seen it's still worth one
point and so investing too much time and
a hard question really is not worth it
and so in that first pass go through and
answer as many questions as you can
while still being careful and effective
then in the second pass you can
prioritize your time and what you want
to remember is that in the SAT Math
section the questions go from easy so
say you have 10 questions or 15
questions in the section questions one
through five or six will be easier than
questions 11 through 15 and since these
questions are worth all the same amount
of points you
you can prioritize your time by going
through and making sure you get the easy
and medium questions absolutely right
since they're all worth the same amount
of points before going on to the hard
ones and so these are a few things you
might do to get better at time
management on the SAT map the other
thing I would suggest is just practicing
with timed with a timer at home so that
you get a sense for how fast or how slow
you need to go so let's see okay so this
was good feedback for the next session
so can you do more difficult problems
could you please do some of the hardest
passport to advanced mathematics
questions absolutely so I can maybe in
our next class have a kind of a trickier
math question to make it a little more
challenging and so we can do that and so
next question will these questions be on
the SAT so yes all of these questions
were example problems taken from
official SAT practice taken from
official SAT practice and which are all
real practice for questions from the
College Board that will show up on the
SAT and there are harder ones than these
there are also simpler ones than these
and so everything that you see on
official SAT practice whether through
the practice questions the time mini
sections or the practice exams are all
official questions that have been on the
SAT in the past and that we've built in
collaboration with the College Board
let's see we have another one of wind
should you start studying for the SAT so
with that I would really encourage you
to first figure out when you're going to
take the SAT so depending on if you're a
junior or senior and if you're thinking
about early admission or early decision
you know figure out what is the right
timing for you to take the SAT and then
once you know that information head to
official SAT practice and create a
personalized practice schedule there
you'll be able to input your information
to say I'm taking the SAT in October or
I'm taking it in August and then based
on today
is date and when you're signed up to
take the SAT wolven recommend that you
study say an hour a week two hours a
week and you can then create that
customized schedule to say I'm going to
study three days a week for an hour a
week since I've got you know some amount
of time before the test so I can kind of
take it easy or if your exam is and you
know two weeks or three weeks you might
want to step it up but that practice
schedule will really help you decide how
many weeks in advance you'd want to
start practicing and how much to study
per week I would say obviously the more
time you have in the more leeway you
have the better let's see so I think we
will be able to finish okay so this is a
great last question what if we were
running out of time and we know we won't
be able to finish is it best to guess so
there is no more guessing penalty on the
SAT and so the answer to that question
is yes if you get a five-minute warning
I realize there's not enough time and
you've got you know 10 questions left
hopefully that's not the case because
you did some time practice and you feel
okay but in that case absolutely guess
so I don't know what your you know eat
what you want to do if you want to guess
all B's all C's or make it random but
you should guess since there's no
penalty for a wrong answer on the SAT so
I think that's all for SAT math for
today but for next week we're going to
do SAT reading and so that it classes
again on Tuesday and for the next class
I would ask you to think about you know
when you're on the SAT reading and
you've narrowed down the answer choices
to either B or C or C or D down to the
final two how should you pick between
those final two answers so when it's
50/50 what approach do you use and so
that's going to be one of the things
that we'll tackle next week with SAT
reading again with some strategies and
some real practice problems that you can
do and so that's it for today for SAT
Math but remember to join us next
Tuesday at 7 p.m. Pacific 4:00 p.m. 7
p.m. Eastern 4 p.m. Pacific for our SAT
reading class and I hope this was
and best of luck as you practice for the
SAT
you